Illinois is the latest state to raise
the legal age to buy tobacco and vaping
products yesterday the Illinois governor
signed a bill increasing the limit from
18 to 21 while statistics show that
tobacco continues to lose its appeal for
young people vaping is skyrocketing
among middle and high school students
well last week the FDA began looking
into whether a cigarette use can lead to
seizures dr. Tara Narula is here with a
push for the 21 age limit nationwide
Tara good morning good morning Nora when
e cigarettes were first introduced to
the market they were seen by many as a
way for longtime smokers to wean
themselves off of cigarettes but what
caught many by surprise was how quickly
vaping has caught on with middle and
high school students the addicted mind
justifies some crazy things 19 year old
Matt Murphy got hooked on nicotine in
high school what began as
experimentation with vaping turned into
an addiction that snowballed into me
having a you know neuro chemical
dependency on it without me even knowing
his addiction followed him to college I
would be studying in the library and I
would have to bike back to the dorm like
every 20 minutes how addictive are these
products nicotine is one of the most
addictive chemicals known to man you
know that some kids are getting addicted
with really just a handful of uses east
cigarette use among middle and high
school students is rising sharply in
2018 nearly five percent that's one in
20 middle school students reported
trying east cigarettes within the last
30 days that's up from less than 1% in
2011 among high schoolers that number
jumped from 1.5 percent in 2011 to more
than 20% in 2018 and that kind of jump
has doctors and health officials
concerned nicotine can interfere with
memory and can interfere with learning
and particularly in younger individuals
18 year old Sarah Ryan is a high school
senior I know very few kids who haven't
been exposed to this issue whether
themselves were through their friends
she calls herself an anti tobacco and
vaping activist the
products are used by kids at every age
and once the legal age to buy these
products raised to 21 these products
shouldn't be a part of high school
culture and eighteen year olds are still
in high school so if the aged purchase
tobacco is 18 then it has a bigger
influence in a younger set of people
because even if you're not 18 and you're
16 you hang out with 18 year olds and
those 18 year olds might be using the
product why do you think it's been so
hard to get this kind of legislation
passed in the rest of the country I
think that there's just the same
arguments about well if you're old
enough to die for your country why can't
you buy a cigarette or smoke or vapor
whatever have you but that is beginning
to change nine states have passed
legislation to raise the legal age for
tobacco and vaping products to 21
hundreds more cities counties and towns
have as well and on Thursday congressman
Robert aderholt of Alabama introduced a
bill that would make 21 the legal age
nationwide younger you are when you
start using a substance the more
vulnerable you are to becoming addicted
and that's because as the brain develops
it just becomes a little bit more
resistant to the neurologic changes that
are associated with addiction Matt
Murphy kicked his habit nine months ago
and has become an anti nicotine advocate
himself his biggest message to teens
thinking of vaping it is way easier to
prevent than it is to stop you know if
you never dig yourself a hole he'd never
have to climb out of the hole just don't
just don't start digging Joule which
makes up about 75% of the e-cigarette
market its health CBS News it strongly
supports raising the buying age for
tobacco and vaping products to 21 Jules
says one of the biggest problems is
sharing by legal age peers the company
says it will continue to work with
lawmakers to reduce youth use rates I
like that guy featured in your piece if
I was his mom I'd go that's my son yeah
just don't dig a hole well insert smart
guy yeah parents do what should they do
well they need to know what these
devices look like because they can be
concealed very easily they can look like
flash drives and they don't have a lot
of odor or smoke that they produce and
the pediatrician really said look let's
be clear and direct
with our messaging to our kids as
parents say I don't want you using these
products they are unhealthy don't skirt
around it parents often make a mistake
and say be safe use good judgment she
said kids are listening even when we
think they're not so well how many kids
cents works with because there are many
kids when their parents tell them things
they go and do the exact opposite I was
one of those you know Sarah said she
knew his sixth reader said it was easier
to find a jewel in school than a pencil
I mean that's a pretty profound they
make those flavors very attractive to
two young kids exactly I think you said
it best so even when they think you're
not listening even when you think
they're not listening they really are
all you can do as a parent is plant a
little seed and hope that they'll pay
attention one day that's right Thank You
Tara